Hello,
hello, hello, hello, I come to you from the corner.
Somebody put baby in the corner.
Chill, Minky.
Today, we'll be a bit more chill.
Sorry in advance.
Nobody put baby in the corner.
I'm baby in the corner.
Minto of the corner.
What is your wisdom?
Block game is fun.
That is my...
That is my wisdom.
Very wise.
It doesn't matter what kind of block game.
Block game is fun.
Um, I did play, or rather, so I played with Matara.
And then I have, I'm in my own world that I was playing
myself too, just kind of to get more used to the game.
But if you guys want me to make a new world, That's okay
too.
Sorry not feeling well myself.
Can you use the same one?
I can show you guys my house.
It's only infested a little bit.
Okay, I'll show you my house.
I'll show you my house.
Do you want a house, Tor?
I can take you to the first, second, third floor.
Why am I on fire?
Welcome to my house.
I adopted this home.
I made it mine.
planted some lavenders around and
sometimes some scallions up here but it's totally not a big
deal nobody's here let's go to sleep oh wait do you want the
house door I can take you to the first
Second!
Third floor!
It's got a sunroof and everything.
Isn't it so great?
Look at that view.
Open view and everything.
I can see the pigs from here.
Wait, what is that?
Why is it rolling?
Wait, I don't think that's a pig.
What is that?
It's gone.
So mysterious.
They're gone.
I haven't explored so much of this.
See?
Well, I did die there.
And spawn is right there.
So if I die, die.
I'm not so far.
I did die there too.
I haven't.
I have only been here.
And, uh, like a little past here.
I have not been here.
Which this looks like the scary area.
It's the scarier, if you will.
We could go wherever we want.
The world is our oyster.
I'm kind of curious what this is, though.
It's just like a random structure.
There's also the blueberry woods.
Hmm.
Search for dinosaurs today?
Yes.
The scarier.
Let's go...
Wait, that's spawn.
I don't know.
Still, I'm getting used to... Oh yeah.
There was one...
Last time I played, there was like a thing that I was
like...
Okay.
You know, in Minecraft, if you press Q, you throw an item.
In this game, you'll have to press G.
I don't know why I didn't just like look it up.
while I was playing but you know yeah I do for throw I also
want to get more iron maybe we'll go kiss Belonkin or
something you know we could do that well let's
oh you have to select the location oh But it...
Does it show up?
I think it might be...
Hmm.
The music is so nice.
See, forget it off of me.
Yeah, exactly.
I've been collecting more lavender because I like it in my
home.
I collect the lavender.
Thank you for the redog.
How's an audio, by the way?
Let me know if I need to turn it up.
Oh, it's overgrown in here.
Am I even going there?
Kind of.
We'll just walk to the water.
What I'm going to do?
I'm going to turn up the volume or the music.
Oh.
we could do
85 and I follow the river
I think one thing about this game that makes it like I'm
still so Minecraft brained right one thing though that you
have to like I don't know that I wish it were more like
Minecraft is that
It's just that I wish it were easier to place down like a
crafting table.
What is happening here?
I've put him out of his misery?
How strange.
You're awesome.
I won't be able to go to your concert in person since my
family is taking me to Mexico.
Oh my gosh, have fun, King of Trash.
Happy birthday, sorry I missed it.
Happy happy birthday.
There's a little thing over there.
Like a little house.
What are these structures?
Is this like a watchtower, I guess?
Wait...
Oh yeah, I guess.
Let's go kill him.
Wait, what the heck?
Cray, I made it.
He's a witch, but the five gifted thank you.
Again.
Blue forest.
Big bird.
I like this kind of looking up and seeing boards or stuff.
It's pretty fun.
I like that part.
Okay.
It's like the most narrow forest ever.
Ew, green goblin.
Oh wow.
This is it guys.
This is it.
Very nice.
Don't come after me.
Oh, he's confused?
One thing that I also have an issue with.
Okay, I'm going to show you guys something.
Watch this.
I put down a torch, right?
Now, as you can see in my hand, I have 30 torches.
Where did that torch go?
Oh, all I did was pick it up.
Shouldn't it add to my torch pile?
No.
It makes a new pile.
And then I know also people say to press Z.
You hear that?
That's me pressing Z.
Holding down Z.
It literally doesn't work for me for some reason.
Oh.
For some reason, I don't know why it doesn't work for me.
So, you know.
Wrong Z.
Yeah, clearly.
It's the wrong Z.
I like to put down things.
Oh, it's a spider's nest now, isn't it?
I think I watched Doki die in one of those.
So, I'm not gonna go in there.
Have you tried removing the Z?
Look at that guy.
That one's fun.
I'm moving the Z, I'm putting it.
Somewhere else.
Now I know there was more blue forest.
I need more iron though.
Trying to upgrade things.
Oh!
Big fall.
This game isn't like normal where you can just dig and find
things.
Or maybe you can.
Maybe I just didn't dig deep enough.
Maybe I gave up too fast.
Here we go.
Oh, foggy.
Pike?
Isn't that a fish?
Ooh, lots of spiders.
Oh, and snakes.
Oh, you don't care about me.
I see some iron down there.
I'm sure it doesn't drop.
I
hate you.
I hate you.
I'll just make a staircase.
Oh, there's a lot down here.
What are those?
Boom shroom.
That doesn't sound good.
That sounds mean me.
A little dangerous.
If you ask me.
Can I get back up here?
Oh yeah.
What was that?
Spider?
I think so?
Spooky.
The music makes it so much scarier.
Oh yeah, jackpot.
Let's go.
I like the way you can see more...
Like, you can see if like a...
Oh, that is a spider.
Oh, shit.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what was that?
We just laughed.
You can't...
You can't get me.
Wait, what is that?
Wait, something's coming to get me.
Oh, shoot.
What are you?
Wait.
I can't reach you.
Ouch.
Oh, shoot.
You're so screwed?
Wait.
I killed that guy, though.
Stop.
Stop it.
Oh, my God.
What are you?
Ew.
Couldn't see anything.
Oh my god.
Not the rat coming over here to finish the job.
It really was a spider.
I'm guessing that's the larva.
Yeah, get out of here, baby.
Oh, there's so much here.
We're gonna have to...
Where's my dirt?
Oh, yeah.
Those aren't gonna grow...
They're not gonna grow up, are they?
I'm gonna have to upgrade my...
thing soon.
My pickaxe.
Also, if you crouch in this game and, like, walk, I think
you can still fall, which is kind of scary.
Mm-mm.
Doesn't lock you to the block.
Yeah, it's pretty scary.
Okay, that should be good.
Stop it.
Grab my riches.
How many did I get?
Oh, 22, you guys.
We're killing it.
There's so much in here, actually.
Wait, did I get all of it?
Did I miss out on you?
Run away, babies.
Run away.
I will kill you.
Oh, shoot.
This damn rat.
The rats are so annoying.
Like, why do you think you're good enough to attack me?
It really pisses me off.
Try not to...
What is that down there?
Oh, it's just lava.
Oh my gosh.
Be careful, everybody.
Just a bet.
I'll have to go back soon, though, because of my...
I don't have my repair kit on me?
Well, I guess we could always, well, I want to make
everything at home.
We could come back and explore down there, too.
Once I have some better armor, since we have a bunch of iron
now.
Deep in the caves, yeah.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, is that just a rat?
Who's like, looking at me funny no I thought I was a I
thought it was a mighty creature I wonder if this will lead
to another outside world like another exit I mean outside
world I'm just still collecting yeah leave me alone Ew!
Oh, that is a creature.
Oh my god!
It was a creature.
More iron underneath?
Oh, you're right, thank you.
Even more.
You think it could- oh, there's so much though!
Oh my gosh, finally!
Iron!
So much!
So much iron!
I should eat.
I should really heal, though.
Yeah, heal up.
We're snacking.
In the cave.
Thanks for this cozy ASMR.
Don't do it.
Don't come after me.
I see you.
I'm just eating my corn.
I cooked this myself.
Sitting in the dark and eating.
eaten oh my gosh it's so annoying like why i don't know i
don't understand this at all like this confuses the heck out
of me for some reason um i don't have another one do i like
don't i only have my copper pickaxe it's fine we can just
grab a couple more it's broken but it still works
I don't have like a cold or anything But thank you guys
You can have several items in your left hand And quickly
switch them by using Z Oh, is that the intent?
I think even if it's a little slower Getting all this is
more important Than not Oh, it's one of those goblin guys
Oh, he's staring right at me Well, he was staring right at
me Come here.
Oh,
shoot.
Come here.
What are you?
You're like a monk?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
That's what I say to you.
Give me your...
I like that you...
When you kill a thing, you get linen scraps.
It makes me feel like I'm stripping them naked.
Okay, we're gonna give up on the copper for now.
How much copper?
Only nine.
That's okay.
It's a fan of me announcement.
Oh, can't wait to see you there.
Thank you, Sarcic.
Thank you.
See you there.
You don't like it, though, that you're stripping them naked?
Oh, my gosh.
Bat, you scared me.
Take that.
Take my...
Angler.
The torches are really bad in this game.
I'll also say that.
They don't do anything.
Oh.
I don't know if there's any parry mechanics.
We could try next time.
I should probably head back though.
It's probably nighttime though.
I'll show you the mine I tried to create before.
Oh my god, yes, I'm overflowing.
Also, another...
Sorry, I don't mean to only say complaints about this game.
Because obviously I'm still playing it, so I'm having a lot
of fun.
But, um...
Is, uh...
To smelt things.
It requires so much...
Wood.
So much wood.
And it doesn't matter if they're sticks or logs, they go
about the same.
They're like...
What is that stair?
Oh, that's a larva.
Okay.
Sorry, I killed your mom.
Okay, let's leave.
They can come back.
I'll leave my torches.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, there's two of them.
Oh, come on.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Ouch.
I forget the swing twice.
Oh, sometimes.
Yeah.
Die.
Could be re-invalence.
Yeah, it's just like, you know, I know the game obviously is
still in early access and everything.
I'm gonna go down there.
But it's my, like, initial, like, complaints.
No biggie.
Nothing that's, like, making me hate my experience or
anything.
Now, we might have to just use my dirt.
Perfect.
There's much more that I like about the game.
Oh, hello.
He choked me.
Dang.
Sick moves.
What are your thoughts on Mint?
on me i don't know something about because swimming
something about her that ain't right don't notice me why are
there so many baddies out right now we'll go the opposite
way we'll go around
we're gonna eat some meat
oh it's a bear i don't want to deal with the bears
You are the baddie.
I'm a baddie.
Green goblin.
Bear.
There's too many dangers in the woods.
Let's hide up there.
Little house.
Right for the taken.
Hold on.
Hold your horses.
Oh, that was pretty.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
A memento's in, like, for food.
I like mint.
The flavor.
Yes.
Wooden shield.
That's cute.
Look how cute this cottage is.
want to take it wait I should get wood that I can replace
for my place I could start fixing my own place looks like a
fixer-upper that never deterred me I can fix her right
now 100 fiber equals 50 coals and 106 equal 50 coals
difference is the time to get the coal.
Hmm.
Wait, what do you mean, fiber?
Like this?
The plant fiber?
Well, I didn't know you could burn that.
I've been burning logs and stuff.
Uh-oh.
Am I out of space?
I can get... I have so much moss at home.
I have so much moss.
You can...
Oh.
I don't like being out of dark because it's scary.
There's big baddies.
Ocean.
Oh, we lived.
Peppermint or spearment?
I like them both.
Follow the river.
Down, down, down.
By the river.
This game is pretty fall asleep and block game speedrun what
do you mean fall asleep
take me home country roads did i put a bed here i think i
did i think i put a bed in here oh yeah In 30 minutes, I
can't even sleep here.
Wait, does this place also...
Oh, he's back.
What's why?
Well, if I die, I'll just respawn right there.
Woo!
Yank, yank, yank, yank, yank.
Oh, God, I'm gonna die.
We didn't die.
Oh, I was like, what's that sound?
Oh, that's like the sound of me dying.
Oh,
wait.
I have these.
Uh.
Oh, it's raw fish.
I don't need bone fragments.
Oh, wait.
Uh.
My stairs.
No, what?
No, I'm not.
There we go.
Punch up.
versus gold
let's go record my memories hello friends give
me my stuff give me my things there's
something that about this music and this part that reminds
me of a game actually the whole thing has kind of been
reminding me of like fantasy live.
like, first-person fantasy live.
Classic fantasy RPG vibe.
Minecraft meets Breath of the Wild as it goes into a little
yo yo yo.
I've already seen it.
I'm glad that the fall damage is much more lenient in this
game.
Okay.
I wanna be my friend?
My home!
I wonder if there's any skellies.
They try to take it over every time.
And I say, uh-uh-uh.
It's my home now.
You can turn it off in world settings.
Fall damage?
No way.
Oh, it's it.
You guys are so persistent.
You're so persistent.
It's my home now.
It's not your home anymore.
I took it over.
It's like my own bone shard farm, so honestly, I don't mind.
There's only two of them anyway.
There's only two of them.
Who cares?
Yay!
See, it looks a die so far.
I had to fill up some holes.
And then I remade the hole.
Essence farming.
I still don't know what to do with the essence.
I'll add it together.
I really didn't grab that much now, did I?
But we have lots and lots of iron to make.
Exciting.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Look, I already have 15.
Which isn't that much either.
Let's just do the charcoal for now.
Oh, never mind.
We'll do my logs for now.
Is this the same world you played with Matara?
No, this is my own that I created.
to go explore in the world without her so and i have oh i
gotta repair my items but i have been cutting down these
trees once i once i break this i'll get rid of it i still
don't know exactly what to do with items that are broken and
i don't want them anymore like you know i don't know what to
do with them
colonizes skeletons home and kicks them off their land well
they should have taken better care of it and disrepair.
I'm modernizing it.
It's crumbling down.
Thank you.
These guys just came from nowhere.
I don't know where their parents are at all.
Where are your parents?
Don't go into the sea.
He'd rather drown than be with me.
I want to build the farming thing.
I need to build the bridge.
But, um...
so that I can have animal friends.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, you can get a shovel?
Oh.
I thought it was fake.
Because I...
Oh, wow.
Nice.
I've just been...
using the pickaxe for everything, but this makes multiple.
Okay, but I feel like I need armor before I need anything
else.
I just don't want head armor, because I think it's ugly.
But we'll get the cure ass.
6 out of 100?
Azure logs, are those the ones in the blue woods?
Oh, I look so cool now.
Oh, damn.
Did it take off my clothes?
okay that's fine sure I'll let you do that it's my favorite
mechanic in the game I don't know maybe that it's like
Minecraft you can hide the armor well now I'm now I'm more
buff I feel more I feel I feel better a little bit And I
really like on my daggers.
But maybe I should have a sword too just in case.
Oh, I need more light leather.
Wait, what's this?
Medium.
How do I get light leather?
Pray throughout the wilds.
I think we gotta go kill some animals.
Small animals.
Oh, like a bunny.
Spider?
Oh, he does come after me.
Yeah?
Ew.
I don't like the way that they die.
It's too realistic.
Where is your mom?
Where are the animals?
Uh-oh.
That's kind of scary.
When there's nothing around.
I think I see a boar over there.
Hakuna Matara, Hakuna Matara, Hakuna Matara.
We did get light hide.
Let's go.
Okay, I don't think a bear would have light hide.
What about a squirrel?
He dies with his eyes closed so peacefully after I stab him
to death.
So sad.
Okay.
Squales don't give anything.
An ugly little skellie man should die.
Actually, let's get the sheep.
Hello, sheep.
Bye.
Nice.
Yes.
Get rid of your entire population.
Yep.
You too.
Oh!
Holy cow.
We're good.
The skies are getting dark.
I think God is angry at me.
Hot dog.
And I think God is angry at me.
I went to Japan, not Kibo, a maid cafe for his time
recently.
Studying paid off that I was able to talk to the maid in
Japanese the entire time, but right now I'm only at the
level where she started washing dishes halfway.
Huh?
Somebody!
You can do it!
They yell, they say no!
No!
What's that up there?
Another mysterious structure.
I haven't really explored the area, so there's a lot of
things that are quite new to me.
Wait, this is probably not a small hide, is it?
Oh, it is a light hide.
Awesome.
They sense their intent.
This is...
This is a funny way to, uh...
Oh, it's a watchtower.
That's a funny way to spawn, though, isn't it?
No, no, no.
No.
What even is this way?
The ocean.
I'm like actually trapped.
What the heck is this?
Why is it so dark?
Pop them to say hello.
Hello.
Take it easy.
You can see it from here.
How the heck do I even get up those?
Ibu.
Like, it's so high compared to the one...
Oh my god!
It's all lava!
Compared to the one that Matara and I found.
Mine's, like, actually evil.
Who's yelling at me?
Evil...
Like, I heard another guy.
But I also see something in the water, you see that?
It's menacing.
Extremely menacing.
It's really scary looking, actually.
Maybe it's just rocks.
Just kidding.
Oh, I'm watching the lava drop.
There's more...
There's so much lava.
House.
House with a view.
Holy.
Glad you're still here with the two things today.
Hope for a better tomorrow.
for a minke ghost-o-she.
Ghost-she.
Thank you.
I always said, too.
Usually, the first day is the worst day for me, so...
I should feel better tomorrow, I think.
Like, what is...
Do you see that?
Like, it's, like, twinkling almost up there.
What could that be?
The area is so...
ominous.
So ominous.
So curious, though.
Once I have a better armor.
I felt, you know, the enemies in this game are kind of
stupid.
So if they aggro on one of you all you have to do is block
and then you can live.
But I don't trust going by myself.
Nice.
Where'd the other guy go?
There you are.
Oh, don't run away.
You can't run from me.
It's good for teamwork.
Very good for teamwork.
The smallest marsh ever.
I like these trees.
They're really funny.
The ones with the curly cues.
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh.
It's appeared.
I see.
Oh.
What am I still grabbing?
Where did the nickname Minky come from?
What a great question.
The nickname Minky I think it originally came from Mint
Eddokie and then transformed into Minky.
Because it's also like...
Mint monkey.
So it kind of works.
Oh look, there's stuff in the water.
Oh.
Wait, what is it?
Are these seashells by the seashore?
Oh, how cute!
You know, I haven't really been swimming in this game very
much.
For a good reason.
Holy...
Did you guys see those?
What the fuck?
What?
Is that like a mosasaurus?
What is that?
Oh my god!
They don't look friendly.
I don't know.
Or maybe they're whales.
Holy!
There's so much below the surface.
You can't see anything.
You would never know.
No.
You would never know all of this is below.
That's crazy.
Crystalline depths.
What?
I see like creatures like walking around up there.
There's...
How would I even survive up in there?
If that much lava is overpouring, I almost wish I could fly
above it, you know?
it out i wonder when we learn how to swim underwater breathe
underwater that was crazy i didn't know that there was life
under the water wait so when when mitara and i were like
swimming over the water that was all underneath us maybe
Wild.
Under, Darcy.
There's two wolves here.
All these sheep and they don't care.
Under, Darcy.
Probably sharks too, most definitely, right?
I think what I do like about this game, though, is that
there's enemies at all levels.
times of day because in minecraft it makes me get too
comfortable in the daytime you know and then at night i'm
like a little i'm a little freak about it i'm like so scared
life finds a way but in this game i can be like and it makes
it also it helps with like not having because you know in
minecraft at night it can become pretty unbearable in some
situations where it's like there's just onslaughts of
enemies on top of you i haven't really had to deal with that
in well maybe just a little bit there are different enemies
at night in this game too like the creepy crawly ones i
don't like those guys but also i wish you had um in
minecraft there's the sound like the sound thing in the
bottom right I wish that was in this game too.
Because sometimes I don't know what a sound means.
Yeah, you could see their glowing eyes.
Yeah, that was fun.
I wonder if all my iron...
Well, it's probably not done because I probably ran out of
stuff to to cook it.
Wait.
Is this the...
This isn't the river.
Wait, what's that black building?
Is that this?
No, it's this.
Wait, what are those?
That guy just spawned in.
There's two of them.
Whoa.
Oh, is this one of those...
Wait.
This spawn's so weird.
Oh, it's the work in progress dungeon.
Oh.
It spawned so strangely.
Does it say work in progress in here still?
That doesn't even say.
Because it spawns so funny.
It doesn't even say that's a work in progress.
It just is like a ruins.
Pardon our dust.
Is this one actually...
able to be accessed?
This one is.
Wait.
Can I take anything of here?
Oh, you can.
I could just dismantle this entire building.
Some kind person in the comments said how this is supposed
to be pronounced.
It's not how Matara was saying.
Like a brazier.
It's like a brazier.
Brazier.
Take the sign.
No, it can't be our house because apparently...
Oh, wait.
Maybe...
But if you're too far away from your bed, you'll respawn at
spawn.
And it could be that that's why when I died that one time, I
didn't spawn back at our base.
Both are acceptable pronunciations, IMO.
Hello?
Wait.
Where is home?
Okay.
That way.
Actually, I should probably...
Probably take this off.
Uh, this.
Oh.
Oh, this is another WIP location.
And then there's lots of eyes.
Oh, gosh.
This place is... Okay.
It's two different.
Holy moly.
Interesting.
And what's that place?
Hmm.
That looks like a goblin fortress or something.
This too.
Like a goblin fortress.
Ow.
I won't hurt you, baby.
You grow up and be nice and strong so I can come back.
Brazier.
Breezier.
Is this the river?
I think I'm...
No.
confused of other places.
They kind of do look quite similar sometimes.
You can do it.
I can...
Oh, there we go.
Breezy air.
Easy breezy, beautiful.
Love a girl.
There's another place here.
Ouch.
Another monument.
No, this is not the same place.
I can't tell anymore.
Oh, it is.
The map looks so big and so small all at the same time.
That means we're close to home.
I really didn't venture off that far now, did I?
I've heard of the Outlanders.
I have, but I don't know it.
Only heard of it.
My home.
We'll finish cooking.
and then we can go explore those scary areas.
Hello, fishes.
Hello.
Oh, guys.
They die so easily.
Fish, fish, fish, fish.
I can't.
I don't like looking at their little faces.
They're like eyes closed.
Makes me so sad.
Any visitors?
None right now.
So at one point I did try to cave.
I didn't get very far before being like, I think I should
just find a cave.
I was like, mmm.
Nice cave.
Thanks.
Oh, I knew it.
Wait, we have a hundred of these.
Then we can make some food too.
Salad.
Lettuce!
Ooh.
Stamina boost.
Oh, I need a type of mushroom.
I hope I didn't, like, get rid of a nice mushroom.
Okay.
I thought I had some cool-looking ones that I forgot about.
Rabbit food.
Yeah.
Alright, that's nice and well.
Let's do our tanning rack as well.
There's no hot dog, but it'll do.
That'll do, Donkey.
That'll do.
I think I have that in here.
My bones.
Sometimes, like, sometimes I'll try to put all, I wish that
it would, like, put all the things that, like, for example,
I had the venom sacks down here.
I wish they would go in.
If I are, you know what I mean?
I wonder if you can cook with lava.
Get buckets and buckets full of lava?
Nice.
Okay, so now with this, I...
Oh, wait.
What if I just make a new pickaxe?
No, I think about it.
That might be better.
I could make an iron one.
Gray old cheek.
NPC also resets every 6 a.m.
in games so you could buy a recipe.
I forgot about that.
Buying the recipes.
Sorry, I have a bit of a method to my madness and I can't
quite remember it.
I can't quite remember what I do.
My method is flawed, maybe.
Wait, where'd that hide go?
Oh, here it is.
I might see more good eyes but i'm really not oh yeah i do
need more of these azure logs oh yeah baby oh yeah oh yeah
check the container options to auto add similar items
Oh!
Sort button found!
It was right beneath my note.
Wait a second though.
Oh!
Da-da!
Dark temple brothers.
We'll put this outside.
for anybody who thinks of coming in.
They'll think twice.
Yeah, it's very menacing.
Very cool.
Look at that guy over there.
What do you think they're looking for?
It's also kind of nice that you can see them with the
torches.
Like they hold torches themselves.
So I don't feel like I'm going to accidentally walk into one
in the forest.
Get a home!
My place looks pretty nice though, doesn't it?
For some place that I just found.
And stoves.
Yeah.
Soft wood roof flat.
I just don't know how much, how did so much dirt get here?
You know what I mean?
I'm slapping it with dirt.
Are you comfy for something you pillaged?
Yeah, exactly.
Oh my gosh, I just noticed the moon though.
It looks really dorky, I'll be honest.
But the stars?
I think it's a BNG.
I was just trying to get that.
There we go.
Alright, let's check this out.
Oops.
Oh, good job, Mia.
We'll find something that matches the vibes later.
No, don't do that.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Yep.
And then we got this half slab.
Oh.
It's not.
what I thought would happen.
Oh, headache and I aches.
I wear glasses.
Couldn't see the stars until I took them off.
Very nice.
Thanks for watching.
Oh, I should reset my home.
My bed, I mean.
Very good.
Very, very good.
I wonder then.
I see.
And then if I, like, had a maybe like this bad boy, right?
Wait.
Why wouldn't it let me?
Let me put it in.
Maybe I don't...
Maybe I only have one slot unlocked?
Look, you said she ended up renting two servers for Hytale.
I wonder if Mint and others will eventually be playing on a
dedicated one.
I would love to do that.
There's about a PC, camera, microphone.
It's a lot of money.
Good luck.
Yeah, Dorko, feel better.
Feel better.
Wow.
Get rid of Saliza.
Only light and shields for now.
Oh, okay, okay.
I do have a shield, albeit not a great one, but it's...
I found this one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Ooh.
Okay, I'm understanding.
You're not through yet.
Keep cooking.
Okay.
Look, oh wait, I had some sticks in here.
Wait, did that finish?
Oh, wait, that, okay, good.
And then I did all my tanning stuff.
Wait, I keep pressing the wrong button.
Oh, bad.
It's this side.
Yes.
Good,
good.
Good, good, good.
Let's make...
I wish I could see what it would look like on me, you know
what I mean?
Before I commit...
What's this one?
Thorium.
Ingrid.
Cobalt.
Oh, we've seen these.
A void heart!
That's what I had!
I had that thing!
In the...
Me and Matara server.
Oh, I had that.
Greater Denizen of the Void.
I had the Void Heart.
Those guys were pretty freaky.
But I feel like I could maybe do it on my own.
Alright, let's make a sword.
Also, I noticed you need the Venom Sacks to upgrade your...
Blacksmith.
And linen scraps.
I need to kill more people.
And this is like crazy.
Whoa.
Stack of iron bars.
Yeah, you know.
Iron bar horizontal.
I haven't really gotten into the building of anything,
obviously.
Cool too.
Wait, I want to see what the...
Oh, my bad.
What the Azure...
Once.
You can't use an Azure log for anything?
No!
That would be so pretty.
We can upgrade my...
My workbench.
Oh, yes, let's upgrade Iron Hatchet.
Craft.
Pickaxe, craft...
Hammer!
It used to alter the appearance of structural building
blocks.
Oh, this is...
Whoa!
Whoa.
Shovel.
Why not?
Hammer time.
Yeah, let's cook these too.
I mean, why not?
Uh-oh, I'm out of light leather.
Very cool.
I guess I just put them in here for now.
I'm not quite sure.
Did I hear a guy?
No.
Sometimes I'll see a big guy out here too, though.
I must protect my territory.
I wonder in this game if you don't sleep enough nights if
something will, you know, come after you.
There's these guys over here.
Let's check what they are.
I see them.
What are you?
Oh, void larva.
Oh, no, no, come back.
I can't see anything.
Oh, my God.
It's one of these.
Ew, void crawler.
You're the worst.
scary.
These guys are sick.
These guys are actually sick.
Ugh.
Nasty.
Oh, that's a biggie.
They're especially cute today.
Thank you.
Sorry, guys, that I'm feeling so crummy.
So sorry.
Nice.
We're getting some void essences love to see it well there's
more they're like coming down yeah bed
my monkey feeling crummy my head is so foggy and tummy hurt
and even though I'm just I'm a spirit it's like hard to lift
my arms.
What did I say we were gonna do?
It's kind of embarrassing that it shows where I died
multiple times.
I wish it didn't show that.
It's embarrassing.
Need more life force?
I think so.
Let's just head this way.
Oh, nope, that's my house.
Sorry.
Head this way.
We'll cut through the swamp.
I wonder if you can build a boat in this game.
Because I think...
Sorry if you can hear there's like somebody's rumbling car
outside.
Um...
I'm just gonna swim and hope that no whales get me.
Wait, if I die in the ocean, what happens in my staff?
Oh my god, he's just waiting there.
Oh my goodness.
They seem almost friendly.
You can right click on the death markers on the map to
remove them.
You can?
Because it is kind of embarrassing.
Oh my goodness, thank you.
Okay, oh it's nice that you can select it though if you're
like...
Oh!
I died!
Oh nice.
Okay.
Very cool.
Swimming, swimming, in the ocean blue.
The day is hot, the water is cold, in the ocean blue.
I'm above them.
That's like coral or something.
What is it?
Front stroke, backstroke, fancy diving too.
Don't you wish it ever had nothing else to do but swimming,
swimming in the ocean blue.
Mario pipes
Let's get in the little Oh even the water Even the water
here Crazy
Evil water Oh
there's like a rare mineral So I think that's a rare
mineral, no?
I don't know if we'd have time to get it.
Oh, it's just copper?
Oh.
No, it's kidding.
It's interesting how, like, broken apart it is, right?
If we got up here, we'd have to be, like, jumping around
place to place a bit.
What the?
Um,
I don't think it's supposed to be like that.
Did they fall off and just sink?
Do you think they'll notice me?
It feels like somebody's watching me.
They can't swim up.
Poor guys.
Wow.
Oh, it's so...
Look at that, though.
That looks like some bad news bears.
Under the sea.
I wish we had a boat, though.
I'm trying to see if there's, like, I mean, maybe I could
start, like, digging up, you know.
From an area.
Oh, we're back to normal.
Never mind.
Definitely.
Oh, yes.
Huh.
Never mind.
Back to bad.
I feel like...
Is that a guy?
Oh, this is like a whole...
Um...
Now, what is that?
That doesn't look so good, now, does it?
It's a troll?
I wish I had been...
I'm not just taking our little swim through through here
just hanging around truly now if I'm is this like the Min
Island let's see because I don't mind digging up like making
a staircase up I think this is good
okay this might take a while but
That doesn't work!
This is rock!
What is shield bash?
Right then left click at the same time.
I think this is slower guys.
Let's keep going this way.
Good to know the other shield bash.
Yeah, but I don't think you can climb up like Spider-Man
after a while.
Okay, I have an idea.
Now that we've collected quite a few blocks.
Also, another thing I miss about Minecraft is being able to
middle click and it giving me that block, you know?
Whoa, we made it!
Just don't fall.
Oh, oh, it's not a feeling I was going to have it.
The foliage.
They don't hurt.
But they're pretty.
I kind of want to harvest them.
My sword.
Wait.
Oh, I feel like that was pretty close.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
It's okay.
Did I actually, how much of my food did I bring?
Uh, a little bit of it.
It's okay if we get, if things go south, Um, all we have to
do is run to the ocean.
Easy peasy.
We just run to the edge of the world, and then, um...
Oh.
And then it should be okay.
Yava.
What am I...
What is this?
It's like all sand or stuff?
Oh!
Look, there's real grass here.
Oh my god, and a guy.
Burnt a zombie.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, okay.
Ouch!
My shield is already...
Done, though.
My bed
is obstructed.
Wait, why is my bed obstructed?
There's a house right there.
Dang, that guy took me out.
so fast why
didn't I take this place anyway not like I kicked my booty
why is my bed obstructed unless someone's standing on it do
you think one of the scaly men is standing on my bed right
now
that guy whoop my butt oh the
chunk didn't load.
Oh, maybe I was too far in that sense.
Aww.
There's a new yak family by my house.
There's probably somebody here, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
There's probably some skillies in here.
I thought that like putting down my own torches would stop
them from coming in, but stop them from spawning, maybe.
Yeah, I know.
Leave me alone.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're supposed to be fixing it.
Okay, okay.
It's all good, we know that the game is in early access.
Maybe I need a helmet.
Or maybe a better shield at least, huh?
Oh, I need light leather.
No.
My current shield I found.
I don't even know what the stats are on it.
Do they have stats, actually?
I guess it just is...
Last longer, maybe.
This wood.
Okay, let's go kill some things.
For some more leather.
Wait.
Yuck.
I don't even know what I lost.
Maybe not that much.
Hey!
Fight back.
Do foxes also?
But the foxes are so cute.
I mean, everything in this game is so cute.
It's kind of torture.
I know in these games you have to to survive, but it's...
It hurts.
Oh, the animals are so cute.
I like the mold of grass.
I don't see any other animals.
Friend the elephant, thank you so much for the gift and
thank you.
A spider house on my house?
Get the hell away.
It's good though, we need more of the...
Poison sax.
Sax, poison saxophone.
Ouch, they all kick.
Squales give nothing.
Where are you going?
Wait, are you a baby?
I think you're pretty small.
Baby.
an adult.
Oh well.
He was fast.
Okay, let's try my stuff and cook on my meat.
Oh my gosh.
We lost all our stuff but we still have the coral clamshell.
Oh yeah.
big stretch
big stretch oh my gosh I have so much so you can cook the
vibe right oh you can look at that guy
getting over to where I died there's gonna be such a pain in
the butt oh oh Because we swam so far.
25 other food?
Weird.
Teleported crafting.
I don't even know you could do that.
Oh, the corn!
Thank you.
I don't even...
I don't even think I've...
I don't think I'm there yet.
Oh, and in the leather.
Oh, yeah.
Oh yeah.
Where can I...
Do I have...
Wait, there was that cave.
That I said I wanted to go and get more stuff in.
I wonder.
Maybe if we dig down deeper in there, we can get better
stuff.
Maybe.
Snow area skellies.
That's how you get the thorium?
No, not there in the skellies.
With an arrow?
I don't think skellies drop anything.
Would you rather get a discount at every restaurant in New
York City or discount at every New York electronic store?
Restaurant?
Maybe?
Thorium is deep down.
is in the desert the desert wait which one is the thorium is
that green or blue
green okay the desert
gosh i think it's gonna be a long long road from here
desert is always south Okay.
To the south, we go.
Shenzhou there, thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
I think I can leave everything here.
Come back for it, maybe, if I need it, you know.
Let's bring...
Tree shop?
Well, I could always cut that, but it's just so I can make
more...
More torches.
We'll bring my logs.
well i'll just leave this one it's only five well this one's
only six whatever it's fine don't worry about it don't think
about it what what else was i thinking of bringing there's
one thing that i was looking for now i can't remember four
and arrow good idea
i can't remember The bed we got.
I guess I'll bring my campfire.
Hmm.
Let's...
In fact, while we're here, we'll just craft the...
Craft them now.
Whoa, whoa, okay.
That was only 10.
We're 40?
How many was it?
More arrows.
I will make more arrows.
Wait, why is it making so ready?
I click a tab and then...
Oh, okay, never mind, it does...
Suck of music.
Oh, my repair kit, that's what I was looking for.
I thought I had one in here.
Oh, I do, okay, two, two, there we go.
we'll find what it is rail cart and a rail backpack upgrade
wait maybe I should upgrade unlocks the backpack when
consumed medium leather wait maybe I should get that we
should okay let's go get some scrap linen scrap and some
heavy oh wait I don't have a cinder cloth scrap but I can at
least get the backpack let's get a linen scrap we know where
oh Mr. Scaly Mr. Scaly there you are wait a second
wait a second Thank you.
For what exactly I needed.
I
always forget that these ones that do like the cool move.
Oh!
My mushroom's.
Okay.
Consume back.
Back?
Oh, wait.
No, just kidding.
medium leather.
What did I think I needed the scrap floor?
No, I'm confused.
Oh, the upgrade!
Oh!
You should?
Okay.
Listen to fire.
Shadow weave.
Lovely.
Break down some items in the base materials.
Oh.
Arcanist's workbench.
Oh, is this what I need for...
Teleport, Hushin?
Alchemist's workbench.
Ooh.
I wonder if I should make a crossbow.
I think I'll do that instead of having the rusty iron
shortbow.
Okay, so we still have a few things that we need to do to
prepare for our grand adventure.
The mono-ultra-microscopic silico-volcano-conosis.
It's the longest English word.
What does it mean?
So we need a linen scrap.
Skellies!
Skellies, where are you, Skellies?
Skellies.
Oh, there's one.
Are you?
How
do you hear me?
And then we need a big hide, or medium hides.
What would be a medium?
Because these are small.
Gosh, that's a big squirrel.
Deer maybe.
I think there were some over here.
Can't see anything.
Cut the grass.
Did I raid this place?
Can't tell.
I don't think so.
They sell their buckets.
Oh.
So sad for you.
What happened?
Disease caused by inhaling too much volcanic dust.
has the oh the volcano in it the name very cool one thing i
hope that they add that i want to really see are like you
know proper villages and stuff you know those are really
cool with actual like little guys that live there and and
all where did i see the deer at
Oh.
I'm totally mistimed this.
Goodness.
Pet clan.
I wonder if wolves too.
The Queebec villages are really cute.
Yeah, yeah, they are very cute when you can find one.
Right out.
Oh.
Oh, sure.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I got ambushed.
I got completely... What the heck?
How is it obstructed?
I wasn't even that far!
Okay, maybe these guys, uh...
These guys should have a medium.
I like you can see their udders.
Oh, hell.
heavy hide.
It's not medium.
I don't have very many heavy hides though.
Might be good in the ground.
Not the ambush.
I got completely ambushed.
That sucked.
I wonder if a bear...
But there's a spider there too, I'm wondering if it's gonna
gang up on me again.
I feel like a bear would be a heavy...
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
Oh, I took him out again.
I don't want to let you...
Heavy.
Okay.
Maybe deer is our only option.
There's nothing in between.
Deer is light?
Then what is medium?
What would medium be?
A wolf?
That's it?
Oh my god.
Oh, I gotta go get my stuff anyway.
How is this obstructed?
This dang game.
Cray animals are all light in this version.
Crossbow health.
I think that's what I'm trying to make.
Oh, oops.
Sorry, I always get them confused.
Oh, no, we have the linen scrub is what we need.
What was I trying to make them?
I think I was trying to make the backpack.
Yeah, the backpack is medium.
I obviously have medium, but I don't know if it's because I
found it in the wild or would.
I just need to kill one guy, one skelly.
You're not a skelly.
Yeah, I think probably the chests are where I found it,
because I definitely didn't kill any wolves.
No, that's a lie.
I did kill one dog,
which I might be able to kill those, but I got to get my
stuff back.
Nice.
Two for one.
Free linen scrap.
Let me see if I can get my stuff back, first and foremost.
There was like a area where
with some one of the guys.
Some ogres.
And they had one dog.
I was able to get him.
Oh!
Hello.
One dog.
Where is my stuff?
Is
this it?
My stuff.
Now they're all hanging out together, it seems.
What?
okay i thought i saw more stuff you can oh my god i can't i
didn't know i didn't know i would leave a bear oh my god i
didn't know i would bald him he's bald all right that's
that's well i got my stuff at least they don't camp it you
know let's head back I know where the other guy is hopefully
they have a dog and if not we forget about the backpack for
now and we just we can go on our event and we get the
crossbow and go on our adventure
devoted to big stick I'm gonna try the deer I believe you
but I still want to see reach them.
They're fast.
I don't have enough stamina for these guys.
Okay, I give up.
There is tasty.
Food.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Where am I?
Red.
Oh yeah, isn't this area kind of cool?
It looks like a pine cone.
And then It's just a big, big, one single big red tree.
It's kind of cool.
Oh.
What is this?
Oh, glowing mushroom.
It does look like a shrine, right?
Like, I haven't touched it because I'm just kind of like,
wow.
Ooh.
I like it for the ambiance.
these guys look like they would be so mean but they're so
nice well not so nice they're just normal but it looked like
they would want to rip my face off but they don't
can you milk them maybe they have otters
nice i think i said i was gonna bring some fiber with me
though We'll leave the shield.
We got a better shield anyway.
All my armor is like about broke.
Let's...
Fishmen have
medium leather.
They do!
The fishmen!
Um...
Okay, that's huge.
What I need is...
Okay, how do I make more repair kits?
Because I feel like I'm gonna...
I will bring my crafting table, you know, obviously.
But, like, linen, scrap, and light leather.
I feel like I'm gonna be needing to repair so many things
soon.
Wait, I thought I had a third one.
I thought I was...
Oh, here's some light hide.
Not too.
Did I...
I must have put them...
Oh.
What did I do with my stuff?
I'm always pressing buttons and I'm not paying attention.
Let's go kill some fishmen.
Bye!
Sixty- not 69 months.
Thank you so much for 21 months.
It's because your name is 69.
That would be- how much time would that even be?
Where did those- where did these come from?
There's a fish man.
Green goblin.
Oh.
Can you come to me?
Yeah, yeah, can you come here?
Medium hide.
Let me see your booty.
Medium hide!
We can do this!
We can make the backpack!
Oh, there's he, there he is.
This is always a thing when you say, I'm going on a big
adventure, and then sneak attack.
Oh, my bad.
Stop it.
Oh, oh, josh.
You say, I'm going on a big adventure, and then it never
happens.
Is that bear?
Oh, shoot.
I think he's stuck down there.
safe it's a cave here though very interesting
any more of these guys i've noticed that they all kind of
spawn in the same places
i haven't searched this whole area i don't know maybe he can
climb somewhere else or spawn somewhere else well i climb i
climb he spawned climb climb Well, yeah, it's one million
side quests before you get to the big quest.
Wait, what?
Stone?
Oh, this is a spear.
I thought it was arrows.
I could have sworn I made arrows.
Oh.
I can't predict those movements at all.
Thanks.
Ife!
Oh my god, wait.
I thought I only had four.
This is kind of awesome.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
He's right in front of me.
Oh, cut your miss.
He's like, why bother me?
Are this guy's going to respawn or what?
um this snake is like in oh he looked like he was taking a
bath it was so funny oh my gosh a big bear and spider what
are with all these mobs appearing
i'd rather not thank you so much for the 10 gift and thank
you
we only got two medium hives
oh you're back
It's fine, I need to heal.
How much was it for the backpack anyway?
Ugh, 8 medium leather.
It'll take forever.
daggers to lunge around very fast yeah you like do i think
it's though and then you can like go in the air
more persistent than plus control of free window it's a
bunch of sales people i got it
it's not your fault it's my fault because i knew that would
i've because i've I've done that before.
Trying that out.
It's not your fault.
It's my fault because I knew it would happen.
I just didn't think about it.
Alright, well, we'll bring...
You know what?
The iron ingot.
We need 10 of them.
Exactly how many we have.
So, we'll bring that and we'll bring...
Oh.
Oh yeah.
What was I saying?
Oh, we just gotta get medium leather on the way.
What is that?
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
Oh, uh, oops, I forgot to make arrows.
Wow, I cook.
I cook.
I cook the fish.
And we...
Oh, and the meat.
I have so much meat to cook, too.
Okay, we cook a...
We cook a cooker.
Invisible mosaic is over the roof.
it and then I'll make some arrows where where are they oh
here actually can I make better arrows here oh they are also
crude arrows well dang I guess it's fine I guess it's a fine
I thought I made arrows but I don't know where they I
thought I made them.
But they disappeared.
Like I'm dead.
Serious.
Oh, here they are.
They did not disappear.
It happened.
No, well, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
First stream I get to catch.
I hope you get well soon.
Oh, bye, cool straw.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Alright, I think we're good now.
to go on our adventure.
Let's make another...
There we go.
Repair kit.
That's three that we have on hand.
Alright.
Goodbye, home.
I'll see you when I get back.
Don't let the skellies overtake you.
Or any spiders, I guess.
South.
Thanks, guys, for helping us.
out.
Explaining how the memberships work.
So cute.
I was over here earlier.
It was somewhere around here, but there was like a ship that
I took apart.
I wonder what the ocean looks like here.
We're close to home.
It spawned.
Let's see what happens.
Oh, he's far away now.
I give up.
I like the music under the water, though.
It's really cute.
The music is very, like, Lord of the Rings sometimes.
It does make me feel like I'm on an adventure.
I hear
A seagull But I see no seagulls Wait, I discovered a A new
fish Lemon peel tang Is that you?
I'm Bilbo Baggins Meantobaggins
Thought I saw A structure over here I'm No, I saw a tree.
South, south we go.
This is the furthest south I've been.
Oh, is that the desert?
It's yellow.
Hello.
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
you're so bad.
I feel bad if it's like your first time catching my stream.
And I'm so like...
Hopefully it's kind of cozy there.
Maybe there's a green goblin in here.
I'll kill him.
Whoa, it's really green.
Stinky.
Stinky in here.
Green Goblin.
Green Goblin, I would like your medium hide.
What is this?
Oh, it's the blood leaf!
I don't know what we need that for, but I want it.
I feel like I just destroyed the whole thing.
Stinky, stinky, nasty!
Perfect stream for study time.
Yeah!
For sure.
I probably should sleep.
I don't want to have to fight some baddies.
I'll sleep in the middle of the floor.
Oh, we can't sleep for another two minutes.
I like how it's very specific.
It's pretty funny, actually.
JB!
Thinking of the Lord of the Ring fandom that cuts in the Mr.
Frodo.
If I take one more step line every single time Sam takes a
step on stream.
We could have told that one, but it sounds so funny.
Sneak.
They're so cute.
Oh!
Come here, Green Goblin!
Yes.
Whoa, the sun reflecting is crazy!
Wait, is that a blue forest over there?
Oh, yes it is.
Let's go check it out.
What the hell makes that sound?
Is this the Azure tree?
Let's try.
Oh, it is the Azure log!
It's mine.
Oh, come on!
Yeah.
Me when I'm hungry.
Me right now.
I'm hungry.
The trees like go so deep into the ground.
It's kind of crazy.
I think we're going to pass through one, though.
Going south?
Yeah, we could just go this way.
The heck is going on in there.
Oh, it's a cave, maybe?
Oh, yes.
Not maybe.
Oh, there's some iron in here, though.
That's cool.
Can't wait for shader mods in this game.
my gosh it'll go so hard it'll be so beautiful do you even
need well i guess i feel like i would add a little a little
more i
think if i added shaders it would be like a very minimal
experience but because so far it's already so good oh i'm
climbing the tree um monkey moating
Uh-oh.
Um, I'm already out of room.
It's fine.
We'll eat some more.
Actually.
The fish is making me hungry the mostest, I think.
Yeah, like, it doesn't need shaders, but I think it needs
shaders at the same time.
feeling.
I get it though.
I'm going to throw out my moss.
Oh wait, yellow moss.
Huh.
Interesting.
And I like that things are stacked in hundreds.
I feel so cute.
I love its art style already.
Me too.
It's so cute.
Back to the desert.
to the desert at the moment everybody ignore that guy
is that it the desert what was i going to the desert for
again no i don't think that's the desert oh gosh thorium yes
thorium oh no there's like hyenas and stuff already i see
them
I need this guy.
Oh, look at him.
He's so cute.
Oh, the little gecko.
Now he's got a fat tail, which means his tail's come off
before.
Oh.
No, please don't see me.
Please don't see me.
I leave.
We're going.
We're leaving.
Oh, gosh.
Ah.
Everything here is trying to... It's true.
Everything in Australia tries to kill you.
Oh, dang it.
Ugh.
Where's my... Hold on.
Uh, ow.
One second.
One second, please.
Yeah, screw you.
Anyway.
Oh.
I thought that was like a bunch of guys together, but it's
just...
A bunch of, uh...
Not deer.
Antelope.
It's this area too.
Oh god, we're like in trouble.
In these areas.
It's the whip dungeon.
I wonder...
What they'll do.
Like when the game gets out of...
Out of, uh...
Like, what's the word?
I'm trying to say.
Like.
What will happen?
Like, say I'm playing on this server forever.
The Badlands.
We made it.
Wait, what is that structure?
Okay, hold on.
Set my bed.
You'll need to make a new world, probably.
Probably, right?
I wonder if this guy drops a medium hide.
Hello.
Oh, so that green thing right there.
Oh, that is a creature.
Oh.
Hello.
Sabertooth Tiger.
Oh my god, he gets like on top of me.
Yeah.
At least he's not running.
in a pack.
Oh, we got him.
What did he drop?
Oh, medium.
Wait, no, I think...
Oh, no.
Meat and medium hide.
It was medium.
Is that a crocodile?
Wait, what's that right there?
We go to the other side.
Why is there no music?
Oh, why is this guy...
Cobalt!
Isn't this the one after Thorium?
Is Cobalt better?
Yeah?
Okay, cool.
Let's go.
I think this guy's gonna see me.
Oh.
How many arrows do I have anyway?
51.
Okay, screw me.
Yeah.
Yeah, death to you, death to you.
What's killing me?
What's hurting me?
I'm in the desolate... Oh, chill, chill.
Was I poisoned?
Oh, I didn't notice.
My bad.
Spook in me for real.
That guy looks a little different.
Okay, I'm so scared.
I feel like I'm in like a bad area.
Holy moly.
That don't sound so good.
Sand swept skeleton soldier.
Okay, so this is...
Holy cow.
Wow!
Boy, this is awesome!
Wait, uh...
Let's see.
Media weather!
Guys, we got the
thorium that,
uh...
Okay, hold on.
There's so much in here.
Silver, oh silver.
Okay, wait, ah, shoot.
Oh my goodness, gracious.
What can I get rid of?
Sandstone cobble.
Actually, here's this little mushroom.
Get rid of you.
There we go.
We're figuring this out.
I'm gonna...
How's my health?
It's not so bad.
Make a chest.
Yeah, but I can't store it in the chest.
Hmm.
Do we have the backpack yet?
Hold on.
Wait a second.
Wait, we can make this.
work we just set up shop right here we just set up shop
literally okay hold on uh we set up shop literally right
here new
home how dare you into the furnace you go anyway um And
we'll decorate with these.
Okay.
And also, um...
Moss.
I don't need you.
Oh.
What does F do?
Besides, like, trying to open stuff.
I think...
Two?
Four.
other medium at home?
Is that a silly?
We need four more, wait no, we need two more.
I think it was six.
Oh, it is eight.
It's eight.
Oh, do we appreciate it?
It's okay.
We're not, we're not, don't count us out yet.
Are you bad?
Oh, you're sad.
Six shots.
Poison again.
Don't land on me.
Oh, what's this?
Ouch.
Ouch!
Oh, gosh.
I'm gonna die.
Uh, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
Where's my...
Oh, my God.
No.
Please.
Ouch, just stop it.
There you are.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
If I die, I'm really close.
I just don't want to lose the durability.
Is this...
Oh, silver!
Fancy!
And then this is just iron.
Yeah, he is definitely a super annoying enemy.
Like, it's stupid, stupid annoying.
I don't want to, like, get noticed here, so I'm kind of
being...
Trying to be a little careful.
I don't want to call the horde upon me.
This place is... This place is so cool!
It's like a little mining factory!
My gosh!
I noticed you.
Oh, we have so much cobalt ore now.
Oh, gosh, sorry.
Oh, my God.
You assholes.
Oh, I lost it.
I wasted it.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to die.
Ugh.
I'm in a hole.
Oh, God.
Oh, geez.
So annoying.
Where did he even come from?
I'll burn these because I only have 100 of them here.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Oh, I need my leather thing, don't I?
Ew.
I need...
I'm gonna make us a little...
A little wall or something.
Maybe the reload time isn't so exhilarating.
One day I'll understand what he meant.
Look, I'm making us a ceiling.
It doesn't get us out of the hot sun.
What is that?
Oh, bone fragments.
Lucky us.
Oh, look at that!
It's kinda cute!
That kinda works!
More bugs.
Well, they're over there, and we're over here, and he's
definitely not flying this direction.
Yeah.
So we're fine.
For now.
If I, though, can make some cobalt stuff.
Like, if we can make a...
Maybe the armory.
Cobalt.
Shadow weave scraps.
I need more of that, though.
How do you beat the game?
I don't think there's a way to beat it right now, right?
Because it's all early access.
Presumably?
I think?
Famous last words.
No, no, no.
Not famous.
Then they're not my last words.
They're just words.
Wait, my bed is all the way over the air.
Wait, careful with uptick.
Graded stations.
Breaking reverts.
What do you mean by that?
Reverts?
What do you... Reverts what?
You'll need to upgrade the workbench.
For what?
I already did.
It undoes the upgrades?
Oh, that's so stinky.
Wait, why would they even make it like that?
Oh, the upgraded...
materials will drop so it's okay okay i guess it refund
refunds you okay oh then it's not an oversight i don't think
that's a bug then because they wouldn't if it were a bug
they i don't think they would refund you you know
it wasn't like this before i don't know why they changed it
that's so weird yeah it's so annoying oh i hope they changed
that let's go get my bed look at the bones whoa whoa whoa I
want to collect the memory of that crocodile actually I
think it's an alligator but you know these crocodiles have
like a skinnier snail look at the bear cat so cute but um
crockagator crockagator well i just broke my bed here hold
on i don't want to die though i don't want to die i'm too
young to die please i don't want to die yet i love how i
just have made my there's like a guy right there and i've
said yeah this is the perfect place this is the safest
location that i could possibly have chosen.
I said, yeah.
I don't need them.
I don't need comfort.
If a guy is, there's going to be a guy.
20 guys on me in two minutes.
Whatever.
No big deal.
Doors, I mean entrance delayers?
Exactly.
Luckily!
Though guys, I think I will call it here for today.
I'm starting to get hungry.
So I think I'm gonna go eat.
But I will be on Doki Bird's channel.
Well, hopefully she finishes Metal Gear tonight.
I think that's the plan.
That will be the attempt.
Crocodile!
I sure don't look like one.
Wow, this place is crazy looking.
Whoa!
It's my home.
Spike, thank you so much for the time!
Okay, thank you.
Hold on, I'm gonna grab these real quick.
I feel like...
for it being like an iron pickaxe, I don't know.
No, I feel like it breaks really easily.
I'm not a fan.
I'm not a very big fan.
Are you dangerous?
Sand lizard?
No, you're safe.
We're now in the desert.
I would, like I said, I would like to really...
We're hiding from the bug?
I would really like to make a server with everybody, but...
You know, we will see how that goes.
But yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thanks for the comfy block vibes.
Feel better soon.
Thank you.
Like I said, I should feel better tomorrow.
Hopefully, I think.
I think so.
If not, if I don't feel better tomorrow, I will.
I don't want to move Alan Wake, but...
Maybe.
Just so that I'm feeling okay for the Tenzetsu Kodam.
I'm not doing double stream again tomorrow if I'm not
feeling good.
But hopefully I'm feeling better in the morning tomorrow.
We shall see.
Alan move.
Targo, thank you so much for the peek.
See you later on Doki's stream.
See you later.
Yeah, I'm going to go eat.
I'm getting real hungry.
So thank you everybody for fun hightail adventures.
And I hope you had fun.
and hopefully it was a little chill and nice for you guys
too so thank you so much oh let me let me set it up so we
read into if you don't know the doki collab we'll read into
that thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you the
doki part there save oh it's a bito alan wait i think that's
like my favorite joke I think Can I make a Spotify for
karaoke?
Wait, what does that mean?
But yeah, Otavito!
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye.
See you.